Let s talk about classic chrome
Recently I made 2 new sony film simulations,
one is a replica after the fujifilm classic
chrome film simulation, and the other one
is a picture profile made after the original
kodachrome 64 film stock,
and in this video I will explain in detail
the main characteristics and differences between
the Fujifilm and the Sony Classic Chrome
Let me know in the comments if you want to
find out more about the Kodachrome 64 film
simulation and I ll make another video about
it
Before we start, remember, all sony film simulation
recipes can be found on my website
Let s start with the classic chrome
this sony picture profile was made after the
fuji film simulation and I used the fuji xs10
to compare the 2 sample clips
As you can see, they look very similar with
some slight differences
They are identical in terms of contrast, fuji
seems to have a better dynamic range but with
worse noise performance and in temrs of color
it s about 90% matching, which is a pretty
good result taking into consideration I was
able to do this in camera only, with the use
of picture profile settings.
As you can see the sony is much much cleaner
and has more details than the fuji, which
seems pretty muddy.
Because of the light gathering capabilities
of the sony a7 III, the sensor capture about
a stop more light than the fuji, so I had
to lower the exposure by one stop to match
the brightness in the 2 cameras, which again
will make the sony much cleaner and has a
clear advantage here.
Unfortunately, with the cine1 Gamma on Sony,
the Dynamic range seems tp be lower than the
fuji at first glance,
but one thing to remember is that the cine1
gamma is a lowlight profile, and has 109%
output,
which means you can recover 9% of the burnt
highlights. And i ll show you exactly what
i m talkin about
as you can see in this image, it seems like
the highlights are completely blown out but
if we start recovering the highlights and
the shadows, we can see that, it actually
contains more detail and has a higher dynamic
range than how it initially seemed like,,
and remember , this is only 8 bit,, on 10
bit cameras you will have a better color rendition
and even less noise.
You could set the profile to Cine4 to increase
the Dynamic Range inside the camera, but the
Noise Performance lowers considerably and
the colors change a bit, especially the yellows
shift towards green, and skintones towards
pink, which for me is a big nono
In theory the cine4 skintones can be easily
corrected in camera just by lowering the color
phase to let s say -2, that will shift the
reds a little more towards orange, but that
will change the whole color spectrum, shifting
the yellows even closer to green, and I honestly
just don t like that for a look.
From my experience, the yellow is the most
problematic of all colors, especially on the
sony s
that s why some companies, like canon, choose
to desaturate their yellows inside the camera
to render Perfect Skintones.
Ahh, fun fact, yellow doesn t even exist,
atleast not how we see it.
The human eye can only capture colors of red
blue and green, yellows and magentas are actually
generated by the brain.
If you don t mind the color shifting of the
cine4, you can definitely use it instead of
Cine1 for Higher Dynamic Range, but only in
well lit conditions. In lowlight situations,
I find the cine4 to be quite noisy without
applying some noise reduction.
So besides that, let s take a closer look
at the colors
The sony reds are shifted towards pink, while
fuji is more orange
The sony greens are more olive while fuji
greens are shifted towards cyan
And the yellows are very close, fuji being
shifted towards orange while sony looking
more accurate to real life
besides that, the rest of the colors are more
or less identical
Overall I would rate this profile 90% identical
to the fujifilm,
and you know, we were really paying close
attention to the color differences, but when
you shoot in a real life situations it might
not even be that obvious, but you still get
really nice colors out of camera!
but still let's bring it even closer to the
Fujifilm I'll show you exactly how to further
adjust it it in davinci resolve for a perfect
match
so in the color tab in the hue vs hue menu,
shift the reds towards Orange,
next take the greens and shift them a little
bit towards Cyan
now drag the yellows just a little bit towards
Orange
and finally, shift the magentas
now let's see the final result
it's almost indistinguishable
to save you some time I will upload this lut
on my website so you can download it for free
So that s pretty much all I wanted to show
you about the classic chrome
let s move on to the kodachrome 64, a film
stock that is more interesting to me
and that is because replicating the kodachrome
64 was, without any doubt, my most difficult
and biggest challenge of replicating any film
stock
let me know in the comments if you want me
to talk about the kodachrome 64 sony film
simulation
and i ll make a video about it!
Till next time, have fun and take care
cya!
Rather than going for the fujifilm kodachrome
simulation, which, for me, did not seems to
look anything like the original kodachrome,
so I decided to go on a different route
Disclaimer
Compared to digital, Film is an organic medium,
which means that results vary even if the
image has been shot same place with same film
stock. It has many more factors that influence
the final rendition of the color. So if you
develop your pictures in 2 places they might
come out totally differently, and that s what
we love about film, the unexpected.
With my film simulation recipes, I am trying
to bring back a little bit of that unexpected
and infuse digital medium with a feeling of
novelty anf discovery. These film simulations
are just an rejuvenation attempt of film and
will not be 100% accurate. That being said,
i hope you will enjoy this video and let s
get started
This film stock is just so complex and volatille,
it s really hard to find 2 pictures that look
alike on the internet
and the fact it s not being produced anymore
it s not making it any easier
The creation of this picture profile alone,
took me about 2 months and at one point I
almost gave up because of the complexity of
the project.
Funny thing is I accidentally created the
kodak ultramax400 in the process of creating
the kodachrome film simulation
so for 2 months I kept searching and gathering
sample photos of kodachrome 64, in hopes of
putting them all together and finding the
characteristic of the film, the so called
pattern or what makes this film so unique
and it was almost impossible to find the same
characteristics in 2 photos, they all looked
like being shot on totally different film
stocks
Asked people on forums and everybody seems
to have a different memory of how kodachrome
looked, the only thing in common, was that
kodachrome was the best film ever made, and
they all loved it!
And finally, after comparing hundreds of pictures,
the only 2 characteristics that I could see
appearing in each photo, was the blueish magenta
tones and the accurate greens, so I went for
that
The whole process was veru frustrating, continuosly
going back and forths , at oone point I think
I had 5 ore 6 different kodachrome recipes,
shooting and testing them all in the same
time to see which one is the best
it was totall madness
That was the point where I almost gave up
Also that was the moment god was like i m
going to give this dude a break , and after
searching some more kodachrome shots, I found
a forum post with 2 images taken in the same
place, same lighting conditions, one on kodachrome
and the other on digital
Wow, now, not only I can finally see an accurate
depiction of kodachrome64 with almost the
whole spectrum of colors, but I can also compare
it to digital and see how the film interpreted
colors, more exactly how are the colors shifted.
Now I can understand why everybody loves kodachrome
and how it gained its reputation
I want to thank his name for posting these
pictures. Definitely helped in creating the
profile
Comparing these 2 shots right off the bat
we can see the dominance of the velvety blues
in the sky,
this is a consequence of the specific developing
process kodachrome had. This film had about
7 chemicals to go through for its development,
very complicated indeed,
and this velvety blues are a consequence of
poor chemical handling
If we continue analyziing the images we can
see how the yellow seems shifted towards green
and desaturated, while reds are heavily shifted
towards pink, being super deep and desaturated.
There is a slight green hue in the brightest
part of the clouds
This part interests me most, can you see the
blueish tones that appear in the hills? Interestingly
enough, they are yellow in the digital shot,
so I am wondering if the terrain changed in
time or it s just how the film sees the colors?
Now I think you can understand why replicating
this film stock was my biggest film simulation
challenge up until now, and i m going to be
honest with you from the start,
with the settings presented in the picture
profile menu, we can only do so much getting
close to the same colors of the kodachrome
64, we need a little bit of post processing
for this look
So the profile I made will be a really good
base giving fairly accurate colors to the
kodachrome, and the fine adjustments will
be done in post processing with the help of
the luts
The luts are called Neochrome Luts the classics,
and it includes multiple looks for the newer
sony film simulations, like the kodachrome,
kodak ultramax400 fuji superia, classic chrome,
classic neg etc
you can find the luts and settings for the
film simulation recipe on my website
If you ever shot kodachrome and think this
profile can be improved please leave a comment
with some feedback and I will try to bring
it closer
Your opinion really does matter and it s making
this community better, so please let us know
what you think
Try all the new sony film simulations
And till next time, take care and have fun
shooting
Cya